Man:
WHEN WE PUT ON A SPACE SUIT,
YOU'RE PRESSURING DOWN FROM 14.7
TO 4.3 POUNDS PER SQUARE INCH.
Man: SO IF WE HAVE THE SAME
PRESSURE AS ON EARTH,
14.7 PSI, IN OUR SPACE SUIT,
WE WOULD BE BLOWN OUT
LIKE THE MICHELIN MAN.
YOU'D BE SO PRESSURIZED
THAT YOU COULDN'T, YOU KNOW,
YOU COULDN'T REALLY MOVE.
YOU'D BE LIKE THIS.
YOU'D BE FLOATIN'
IN SPACE AND DOIN' THIS.
SO WE LOWER THE PRESSURE
TO 4.3 PSI
SO WE HAVE ENOUGH PRESSURE
TO BREATHE FOR OUR LUNGS.
BUT WE CAN ALSO MOVE
AROUND IN THE SUIT.
Man: A SPACE SUIT WEIGHS
ABOUT 275 POUNDS,
WHICH WOULD MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO MANEUVER ON EARTH.
BUT IN THE WEIGHTLESSNESS
OF SPACE, IT'S NO PROBLEM.
Man:
IF YOU CAME OFF STRUCTURE
AND STARTED FLOATING IN SPACE,
YOU COULD REEL YOURSELF BACK IN
TO THE SPACE STATION
OR THE SPACE SHUTTLE.
Man: BUT IF YOU UNTETHER,
ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN IS THEY CAN FALL
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE OF EARTH
AND BASICALLY BURN UP.
BUT THERE IS A RESCUE
DEVICE CALLED A SAFER...
Man:
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO FLY AROUND
LIKE GEORGE JETSON,
LIKE A JET PACK.
Narrator: BY USING YOUR SAFER,
YOU CAN RETURN SAFELY BACK
TO YOUR SPACECRAFT.
[ OPERA MUSIC PLAYING ]
Man: WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT
THE PLANET
FROM THIS VANTAGE POINT,
IT BLOWS YOUR FRICKIN' MIND.
IT'S ON MY BUCKET LIST.
NASA, PLEASE LET ME
GO TO SPACE.